hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to the
transition from stand-up comedian to
other forms of media certainly is hidden
this I mean for every home improvement
or a Seinfeld you get a soul man or
whatever the hell that Richard Lewis
show was and indeed one of the messiest
transitions had to be with a comedian
named Carrot Top a very bizarre comic
who made most of his living making
strange and surreal prop jokes for some
reason somebody thought this would
transfer well to film we can only hope
that that person is in a short line for
the guillotine this is chairman of the
board
the only carrot a movie ever made that
Jesus chairman on the board shows the
feeble attempts of what happens when an
unfunny script is given to an unfunny
director starring an unfunny actor the
result so let's take a look at why
chairman of the board should have been
shredded like carrot juice okay so the
movie starts off with the birth of our
main character and oh yeah you really
want me to walk out early on this movie
don't you so yeah be having guests yet
the movies pretty much fixed around
unfunny cartoon humor don't believe me
here's an unfunny cartoon this whole
opening looks like that mathematics game
you played in first grade you know the
one that tried to entertain you but by
the end you just want to eat the fucking
screen
we cut to a home that we've seen and God
knows how many other films actually I do
know too many as we come to our main
character named Edison getting up in a
way that's also been used a bajillion
times we see his landlord played by
George Costanza mom as it turns out
she's throwing Edison and his roommates
out for not paying the rent
yeah she's using a voice box because
they thought that get around the fact
that they're totally wasting a funny
actress tell me you did not spend the
rent money on another one you get this
is the surefire winner it's the pet rat
for the 90s that's what you said about
the anatomically correct fanny pack then
let's not forget the glo-gunk the night
serpent and let's not forget the
handy-dandy kicked up helper and other
failed jokes from his stand-up by the
way if you haven't noticed yet every
other shot in this movie is shot in a
wide-angle close-up cuz that's just how
I want to view the face of Weird Al
Yankovic's anus here isn't it you need
to get up a job like a job job so
lettuce and goes through a bunch of
throwaway jokes to try and find a job he
even tries out for any Wow but that joke
fails before it even set up
during his search he comes across an old
man whose car is busted
of course Edison's invention safe a day
yeah I think I can see where Tom green
got his inspiration I'd appreciate a
ride to the beach I think I still have
time to shred a few ways before I sunset
you surf
of course he serves he didn't just bring
his dump double for nothing did he
yeah why don't you get off the obviously
not moving surfboards and try it for
real this time
so after he'd be friends the old man he
gets fired from a job working his Big
Bird's crack baby when suddenly he gets
some sad news
no what yeah Wow he must have wiped out
this movie pretty bad
not that I blame him I mean ten minutes
of this movie will cause anyone to burn
their contract but still it's pretty
prison we then come across our villain
played by Larry Miller and give him some
credit he is the only guy who's
producing a funny life once in a while
later Bradford Dodd will have my
condolences um hello Raquel Welch it's a
done deal
baby goodbye Raquel Welch he makes an
ass of himself next so while Miller is
hoping to be named the new head of the
old man's invention company yeah I think
you can tell where this is going he
turns over everything to Edison because
he served with him once I leave my
entire shocked Holdings 45% of McMillan
industries to my new friend
Ed's well unfortunately he didn't say
Edison's last name so legally this one
fly but in the magical world of bullshit
land he becomes the new chairman of the
board can't believe she let one rip
our first ride up is a group oh come on
own up to it you know that five-year-old
who tells you a horrible joke that
you've heard a million times but you
listen to it just to be nice
I'll enjoy a whole movie like that I
thought you said this inheritance was a
sure thing I know I should have had my
uncle committed years ago but I was up
all night with my lawyers
he turned the will inside out thank you
that angle from Larry Miller's balls
really ended alert to that scene
so while Edison is getting shown around
the factory he accidentally gets himself
covered in post-its because that's all
he's got he also shows Edison the
invention room which hasn't been used
for years but of course
Edison decides to put it back in
commission and wait a minute Edison like
Thomas Edison the great inventor I just
got it and everybody in the factory
couldn't be happier that is except for
the fact that their pay was cut to make
up for all the inventions causing them
to strike and not give you all the Rays
right now sorry
and give you something better huh a
stake in the company I'm not making
every Wednesday afternoon Wednesday is
the most easily led staff in all of
history you know the answer to
everything isn't simply a beach party
this isn't Saved by the Bell he's really
a great guy
Shayne and yet you're still gonna be his
girlfriend at the end so luck so Larry
Miller has a diabolical plan to trick
Edison into running the company into the
ground by having him make terrible
business decisions so yes chairman of
the board is officially ripping off the
Flintstones movies they don't even find
a good movie to rip off they just went
to the lowest form of creative scum they
could find at the time it's like trying
to rip off a rock what could you
possibly gain from it
oh go see what a surprise hello Raquel
Welch now get busy
goodbye Raquel Welch so in order to try
and control Edison more Miller takes
into a racquet club really that's the
best logo for a record club you could
come up with since it's your first time
I'll go easy on you oh for God's sake
did the cameraman just fall there did
the shittiness of this movie just
overtake him and he had a collapse to
the ground
yeah we got it he sucks at tennis
please move forward it's very impressive
you know Edison being the leader of a
major corporation is about more than
playing video games or settling a strike
your invention idea what about it yeah
he's gonna drink the water they're just
stretching it out please move forward
you have to feel the balls caress them
instead of whacking them and think of
your racket as an extension of yourself
for the love of butter these jokes are
too predictable I mean you can just
replace the dialogue with dick joke dick
joke dick dick dick joke dick joke dick
joke penis so while they continue to
figure out how to make the movie funny
Edison finds he really starts to hit it
up with the cute blonde who also works
there named Natalie I've got some lunch
oh oh no I can't who can do my eyes oh
you're thinking about right now
is everyone good move back into my eyes
nothing please try to make it
semi-realistic that I find you funny all
right all right so of course he hits her
up for a date as they go to a History
Museum to eat lunch as a Native American
and a cowboy what makes you think I know
so they go around and look at all the
other inventors from the past because
being an inventor he obviously knows
nothing about other inventors well
access to devastate static electricity
watch what happens when you put your
hands on it go ahead wow you can do that
effect without even putting your hand on
it cool so Edison finally comes across
his most brilliant invention a TV dinner
that actually is a TV as well hi I'm
chef Edison and when I'm away from home
I still like to catch some of my
favorite TV shows that's why I always
bring one of my chef Edison TV dinners
wherever I go with flavors like uh Mavis
and broccoli and YPD blue berry pie and
mash potato
it's not raising to be a couch potato at
home you know I'm just gonna start
working on the apology from the
filmmakers dear Phil viewers we are
extremely sorry for the film we have
given you on you should have known
better and will remember next time to
treat you like you have a brain sorry
sorry sorry sorry sorry
so again just like the Flintstones movie
Edison becomes rich and starts to act
like a jackass to all his friends but it
turns out his stock starts to plummet
when somebody reveals that they got
radiation poisoning from one of his TV
dinners this of course results in his
fortune being totally destroyed the
madman going like a jack-o'-lantern
Edison how do you explain that I don't
know but I promise you it's gonna blow
over your ignorance is no longer
charming his ignorance was never
charming I think it's time to elect a
new chairman
so now Miller is put in charge of the
company as he plans to sell it for a
whopping big sum of money got Vic did no
tell me this isn't happening my
surfboard dinosaur they even took the
Gallagher DVDs I was stealing from but
Edison makes an amazing discovery that
guy in the video it turns out didn't
have radiation poisoning it was just a
special kind of makeup the whole time
well why didn't somebody just do a test
on him no doctors check to see if you
really have it no official diagnosis or
oh who cares man desperate for jokes
coming through why are they dressed as
crash-test dummies you might ask she's
gonna do another video another video so
Edison comes in and tells everybody
about Miller's evil plan
by non-toxic welcome and anyone complain
they've exposed to radiation
this whole toxic TV dinner thing was a
scam wasn't it okay so you could get
control of this company
you stole my former fort well done
didn't you the plastic lid we found in
the secret chamber gave him away and
aleksander's is their descendant Miller
tries to prove his innocence but luckily
he happens to be wearing one of Edison's
inventions compulsion which always
points out what he's lying why would he
be wearing that to begin with that slow
shirt of yours is worth millions
hello Raquel Welch oh shut up Bradford
goodbye Raquel Welch some of the
business is back to normal Miller is
taken away end oh you gave up Melrose
Place for that oh really
this movie was inspired by somebody yeah
some jackass keep up to carrot top and
said you should do a movie okay this
money's hard it's a shame because I
think your tub can actually be funny I
mean I've seen a Matthew can be central
roads and even Reno 911
my god is he annoying here he's like
Yahoo serious if you would shit it up by
a donkey
the jokes are lame the cinematography is
weird sometimes you'll get a funny line
from Larry Miller but that's far from
saving the movie it's horribly written
poorly acted horribly directed it's just
harm it's just proof that the stand-up
comedian wants to do a comedic spin-off
they have to put a lot more effort into
it than this I'm Anastasia Creek if
you'll excuse me I'm off to start my own
comedic spin-off critic and trout
the bigger love the
Emily
yada yada yada yada do